new information ties President Trump to
his campaigns efforts to silence women
who claim they had sex with him more
than a decade ago CBS News sources
confirmed the president was in the room
when his then attorney Michael Cohen and
National Enquirer publisher David pecker
discussed paying hush money in August of
2015
Norah O'Donnell is reporting from
Washington this morning Norah good
morning good morning that's right in the
room where it happened that's the phrase
this morning Cohan pleaded guilty to
breaking campaign finance laws in
connection with hush money payments so
we're starting here in Washington this
morning with Weezer Jiang who was at the
White House where the president denies
knowing anything about them at the time
we should good morning good morning Nora
president Trump is pushing back hard
claiming those accusations are only
being made to make him look bad even
after Michael Cohen was sentenced to
three years in prison in part for
pleading guilty to those crimes the
president is denying nothing at the
Trump Organization was ever done unless
it was run through mr. Trump he directed
me to make the payments he directed me
to become involved in these matters in
an interview with ABC News Michael Cohen
said the hush money payments to porn
star stormy Daniels and Playboy Playmate
Karen McDougal were made to impact the
election you have to remember at what
point in time that this matter came
about two weeks or so before the
election post the Billy Bush comments so
yes he was very concerned about how this
would affect the election let me tell
you I never directed him to do anything
wrong
President Trump said when it comes to
breaking campaign finance laws the only
thing he did wrong was trust a bad
attorney and you know what in retrospect
I made a mistake because I hire usually
good people CBS News has learned mr.
Trump attended an August 2015 meeting
with Cohan and National Enquirer
publisher David pecker where the hush
money payments were discussed it's not a
campaign expenses a personal expense
last night counselor to the president
Kellyanne Conway disputed that people
saying we did
in furtherance of the election there is
just no proof of that
that is somebody's opinion president
Trump's statements on the matter have
evolved from being unaware in April
now he says the payments were simple
private transaction and that there are
ulterior motives to calling them
anything more they put that on to
embarrass me they put those two charges
on to embarrass me raids of Cohen's
properties have also launched a criminal
investigation into president Trump's
inauguration spending federal
prosecutors are looking into whether
some of the donors who gave to the 107
million dollar fund did so in exchange
for access to the president in a
statement the inauguration committee
said the donors were vetted in
accordance with the law and that no
improprieties have been found and press
secretary Sarah sander said the
committee doesn't have anything to do
with the president Norah
they are following the money all right
we should thank you